I went to a taping once and and you had
a new material was it new material
Seinfeld that made me laugh really hard
I who did that voice Joe DeRosa okay oh
yeah yeah new material Seinfeld was
something I used to do just to make
people laugh I was like well what's a
cop right glasses glass bowl but it's
all terrible tombow Hollywood Bowl why
is it a ball is that a ball it's a show
Shell Gasoline it's not gas it's a shell
what's a dinosaur fossil fossils James
you put on James diesel Vin Diesel does
he wear Diesel and like you just work
and do it they're gonna go is that
anything
he'd have a pad
do you feel he did it justice
he was great what were you gonna say in
tripped I well I was going to compliment
and say a true comedian you knows that
the joke is is that anything yeah yeah
like someone watching is like I like the
part like no
one of our writers I remember he wrote
this joke it was so Seinfeld it was so
good it's really a testament to how
clear Seinfeld's voice is I'm not saying
that yeah just to kiss his ass but I'm
kissing his ass a little bit but he's
like he was like uh macaroni they always
have the uh the clear
windows yeah because
meanwhile cereal's over here in the dark
why is macaroni getting a room with a
view I was like that is a great that's a
great joke it's ready to go that was a
great show
yeah it's so ready to go yeah so cut to
me this is actually kind of a
synchronicity because I went to The Palm
restaurant for the first time yesterday
first time since this happened the first
time I went to The Palm restaurant which
is like a famous yeah Hollywood
restaurant like very sweet the faces of
famous people yeah yeah and they bring
you a prime rib and a martini at 11 A.M
so I went back with my wife and I was
like this was yesterday we just wanted
to disrupt the the simulation we have a
four-year-old and we're like let's just
do something we would never do let's go
let's go to the Palm we don't really I
mean we're like let's see let's give it
yeah we did I haven't had steak in 10
years and I was like oh my God because
the first time it wasn't that great by
the way yeah it wasn't worth it not
[Music]
but it was good because if I ate it and
I was like what have I been doing and my
body didn't feel great I'm a positive
blood type that that's better with
chicken fish oh interesting it's an
interesting book Chinese medicine let's
wait for the blood results
want to play them online yeah I know I
mean I would more steak in your diet you
need more steak it was after my doctor
so I gave blood that was one of the ways
I Justified it I just lost a lot of
blood I should eat iron yes you could
also eat lentils anyway we went to the
palm and I was telling this story that I
was like the first time I was there was
Jerry Judd apatel my dear friend uh and
I mean that like we're actually very
close I love him very much and we talk
all the time and I don't know I'm
getting sweaty about that I just mean
like he's just a like he's just a combat
he's just like a new balance he wears
this shirt every day I'm dressed like
him regular guy and I love that we can
be Pals and um he invited me to this
thing that Jessica Seinfeld so Jerry's
wife okay was having a fundraiser and I
was laughing with Val looking back that
I was like that had to be like a five
maybe ten thousand dollars oh yeah seat
and Judd like class classic rich guy
thing didn't have anyone to go with me
I'm sure Conan's been like Sweeney do
you want to come to Mexico he's never
asked me no hitchhanker's having an
Easter egg hunt yeah I gotta show my
face and I'm laughing I got that
invitation
Conan what's your date Conan yeah
I'm just kidding I have nothing but
gratitude anyway but I I didn't I don't
really eat meat even though I ate steak
yesterday yeah I still don't consider
myself a red meat eater so I they're
bringing out these steaks these
incredible steaks Jason Bateman is there
Judd is there and then I'm like I don't
even they bring me the saddest mushroom
I've ever seen in my life it was a ten
thousand dollar Portobello and I had I
was just thinking about Judd being like
uh-huh I paid for this I invited the
wrong so that was to redeem
that here's why I bring it up because
I'm counting it as a synchronicity Jerry
Seinfeld is there of course this is the
man who changed my life I saw his movie
right yeah and I moved to New York and
everything changed
um he comes up to me I have no stories
like this yeah I'm in a dumb Blazer like
a Sunday school student he looks amazing
he walks up to me and he goes what's
with the mushroom I guess I'm sorry yeah
mushroom cap it's not a hat
it's like it's a shame it's not
graduating it's not graduating
move the fungi I'm a fun guy
[Laughter]
he says but I also blow it in the story
I think she goes I he goes I just want
something he doesn't do it he's a
regular boy
you're doing it
because I saw that new material so I
found that oh oh god wow I loved it I
love it and I this is where I think I
blew that but it was honest I couldn't
stop myself if I try
to quote your friend Mick Jagger from
these days thank you wild horses
couldn't have stopped this I went like
this I went
you know he he rolled with it but I was
like that's exactly like an episode of
Seinfeld where you cut to the diner he
did the mind blow yeah
because it took up too much space yeah
my wingspan is just too great it's like
the conversation I I think I did manage
to squeak up thank you for making I'm
sure you did yeah I think you're over I
think you're being that seems like a
totally normal I appreciate nice
response I mean but it is you're
narrating the moment in the moment which
is what's funny how many of you have
seen it yeah
somebody probably sent him the YouTube
clip to be honest but like it was it was
a highlight for sure so cool